[MUSIC PLAYING]
LEIGHA JARETT: In
this video, I'll
be showing you how to create
an experience management data
warehouse by transforming
and centralizing
your survey responses.
My name is Leigha Jarett.
And I'm a developer
advocate from Google Cloud.
Surveys are a powerful tool
for all different businesses.
Survey platforms allow
organizations to easily collect
large amounts of data around
customer satisfaction, employee
happiness, brand
awareness, and more.
However, surveys
are often used once
to solve a specific
problem and then
the data is forgotten about.
Additionally, the
shape of the data
can be pretty difficult
to work with using
standard tools like SQL
or business intelligence
platforms.
Here, I'll show you how to
use Cloud Dataprep by Trifacta
to transform and load survey
responses from Google Forms
into BigQuery, where you can
join them onto additional data
sets and perform deeper analysis
using tools like Looker or Data
Studio.
Let's imagine that I'm
performing market research
for my data analytics company.
I sent out a Google
Forms survey that
asked respondents
questions about
their analytics knowledge.
Google Forms will automatically
push the responses
into a Google Sheet.
However, if I pushed the sheet
directly into my warehouse,
the format would make
it difficult to query.
Let's take a closer look at
this checkbox grid question.
In the Google Sheet,
one row is recorded
for each response, where each
grid column is its own column.
And the selections are
all in one cell, separated
by a semicolon.
Now, what we really
want is for one row
to represent each selection so
that we can easily do things
like count the number of people
who selected each platform
project combination.
In Cloud Dataprep,
I've created a flow
that transforms and loads
my responses into BigQuery.
I've connected the
Google Sheet that
contains my survey responses
and then created a recipe
to clean the column headers.
Next, the data is pushed into
four different recipes, one
for each question type, which
transforms the responses based
on the format.
Let's take a deeper look at the
multiple-choice checkbox grid
question.
In my recipe, I can
preview the data
at each step in my
transformation process.
I've already deleted the
columns that I don't need.
And now I want to extract each
element from my selection list.
First, I'm going to
extract the selections
into their own
individual columns.
Next, I can combine
these columns
into a single array
for each response.
Now that I have all
of my selections
in an array, what I need to
do is restructure this data
so that each selection becomes
its own row in the database.
And there we have it.
My data is now un-nested.
I can repeat similar
transformations
for my other formats until
I have all of my data loaded
into BigQuery.
In BigQuery, I can
see that Trifacta
has pushed those responses into
the four tables representing
my different types of questions.
I can preview the data and see
that it's now in the format
that I would expect it to make
it easier for doing analytics
on.
And since all this data is
centralized in my warehouse,
I can easily join it back
onto other data sources,
like the accounts
table from my CRM.
In Looker, I've created
my own dashboard
that surfaces insights about
this survey to my team.
Here, I can drill in and see
which respondents correspond
to accounts already in
our CRM and directly
reach out to the account
owners to let them know.
I'm also going to
jump down and drill
into my group of users
who are data analysts
that leverage Python.
I'm going to hop into Looker's
explore environment, where
I can easily now send this
list of users to Marketo
and target them for an
upcoming launch that we have.
And now you know how to create
an experience management data
warehouse, where your
organization can take
direct action on the
insights that they
get from survey responses.
Thanks for watching.